[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
m
ce soir on est ici pour le lancement du
texte fort bhutto 2019
cette fois vous tous en fait c'est
l'occasion pour nous de sensibiliser à
l'innovation technologique au service du
bien commun
le groupe et le lancement en proto 204
sur le plateau de saclay qui est la
première ville de notre tour de france
toutes sortes qui nous attend c'est une
table ronde qui viendra questionner un
peu le rôle de différentes technologies
dans la résolution des enjeux sociaux et
environnementaux d'aujourd'hui et
ensuite on va passer du temps à soutenir
ou à créer des projets take for good
donc il s'inscrit vraiment dans cette
dynamique de l'utilisation de la
technologie pour avoir un impact positif
que ce soit en lien avec le combat face
au réchauffement climatique
vaincre le cancer aider les personnes
sans domicile par rapport à leur
situation
toutes les thématiques qui nous concerne
aujourd'hui dans la société
on aura des pitchs d'entrepreneurs qui
viendront présenter un peu en
inspiration bat l leur solution
take for good par exemple on a can save
en jackpot pour pouvoir apprendre à
faire les gestes qui sauvent
ensuite on va passer à une dans une
dynamique on va mettre la main à la pâte
donc dans différents ateliers pour voir
comme je disais soit créé un projet take
for good soit soutenir des projets
existants par exemple ce soir sur la
table ronde on a quand un qui vient du
lot techlam donc qui cherchent vraiment
référence et un maximum de d'innovation
qui demande peu de technique peu
technologie et ils les mettent à
disposition d'un maximum de monde ont
fait flotter club s'est développée
diffusé promouvoir des lots technologie
donc l eau technologie qu'est ce que
c'est c'est des solutions techniques
simples utiles durable accessible qui si
elle était appliquée à grande échelle
pourrait répondre aux besoins de base du
plus grand nombre et on estime que
finalement résoudre un problème sociétal
environnemental par de la tech c'est
bien ce qu'ils attaquent et pas
elle-même un problème sociétal et
environnemental
on a fait des risques de l'audace qui
créent des outils numériques au service
de structures d'intérêt général du qui
viennent du monde de l'urss et on à
vincent qui vient du design spot qui est
un peu un lieu clé pour les étudiants et
chercheurs en design à saclay juste
après ça on enchaînera sur un cocktail
parce qu'en fait ce soir on a plein de
personnes de profils variés dont l'idée
c'est vraiment perte du lien entre les
personnes qui sont à la fois actrice de
l'innovation sociale et le personnel
sont avec les ovations technologique du
qu'on profite de ce soir un peu comme
une plateforme pour pouvoir faire du
lien dans cet écosystème qui est un peu
disparate
[Musique]